[Music]
we're here to talk you a little bit
about dry January so what happens in dry
January so dry January is a rare
opportunity in our industry to force
ourselves to just dry out because you
can imagine being surrounded by
delicious things all the time many of
them containing alcohol and especially
having it been a wild year like 2016
things just build and build and build
and you just need a break so Ryan
graciously offered to suggest some of
the new alternatives you were gonna dry
out in your january yourself so what do
we what are we looking at so the first
thing we're looking at today is Old
Faithful you have to have a beer in your
repertoire and there's so many
non-alcoholic beers out there we we had
know a few of them by name
we're not going to name names but here
they have a reputation for really just
not being good right so the biggest
traits I'm looking for is I'm looking
for a nice mouthfeel I'm looking for
aroma and I'm looking for flavor and if
I can really have those things and have
it be in smart package sigh meeow I
think one of the things that's really
special about it is having that robust
carbonation it just really resets your
palate you could really imagine yourself
having it with a meal and it's just not
boring wines a little more of a
challenge
wine is a tricky one we've already
looked at having alcohol without alcohol
but how do you have wine without wine
alcohol is essentially a solvent you're
dissolving flavors and aromas in that
alcohol and then the alcohol is carrying
those flavors in aromas mouth up through
the back nose that's how you're
perceiving what you're drinking when you
don't know the alcohol you're not
carrying any of those flavors typically
when you take the alga out of the wine
you're subtracting all of what was in
the grape in the first place and you're
taking away the alcohol to carry any
flavors that come out of the
fermentation process which is an
elaborate one with one and so the
interesting thing about trying to
purchase one is that they they tried to
approach it rather than making that
awful wine they said how can we apply
the same model that we've used with
winemaking to make a really elegant
grape juice so the thing that's fun
about it is it has a lot of the same
mouthfeel as wine and you have some of
the same acidity and some of the same
sugars so it actually stands up to food
too and that's something that's really
exciting about it it's really great for
resetting your palate that if Sydney
just really complements whatever you're
eating and so unlike just drinking your
normal Great Physician it's fun yeah so
it actually has a little bit of an
- it's about those aromas it is as you
would expect a lot sweeter yeah but like
all the other complexities that are in
the grape that translate through to the
wine do stay in the in the grapes
they're using yeah so I feel like one of
the hardest categories to replace one of
the things you really miss especially
after one of those rough days is a
spirit how wait how is the spirit not an
alcoholic
how does it work essentially what we are
hypothesizing is that they've mastered
they've macerated these different
botanicals and alcohol and then they've
used a still to extract the the water
that's also been in there and then
recommenced the vapor the way they're
characterizing the flavor this one is
leaf herb and pod and they say that
that's based on peas so so I can smell
it from right here yeah so it has a it
has a really intense aroma and we
disagreed about this I so get a lot of
pickle off the nose yeah and and I and
that made me wonder if they were if
there was vinegar involved I think there
is yeah but it does make me wonder if
some of the classical pickling yeasts or
or therefore the bacteria does not be
involved with the lactic bacteria yeah
are involved in this somewhere that
they've got some of that fermentation
too because I think there's some lactic
acid I mean come very first this would
be a great pickle back yeah that's right
for your bourbon trust me this is we're
already mixing yeah see we're already
talking about it and we've got how many
days left right yeah this is not looking
good